If you're wondering who "Ada" is in all of those strings,
Ada is Augusta Ada King, who is arguably the world's first computer programmer.
Back in the 1840's, in England, she started to think about how to program mechanical computers--
Charles Babbage was proposing to build such machines--
and Ada was the first person to really think about how to program them.
Grace Hopper wasn't the first person to think about
doing things other than arithmetic with computers.
Back in the 1840's, Ada was already thinking about that.
You can see this quote here from her:
"It might act upon other things, besides number,
were objects found whose mutual fundamental relations
could be expressed by those of the [abstract] science of operations..."
The "it" that she's talking about is the analytical engine that Babbage was proposing to build.
He never succeeded in building it--
in the 1840's, the technology for building it
was not quite good enough to make a machine that precise.
But he had a design for it,
and Ada was thinking about programming it to do more interesting things.
The quote goes on to talk about actually using it to compose music.
["...and which should also be susceptible of adaptations
to the action of the operating notation and mechanism of the engine..."]
People do use computers to compose music today.
It's debatable whether or not you actually want to listen to that music,
but certainly it's something computers can do.